this is one of those funny stories about
the pot calling the kettle black that
reflects the total blind
hyper-partisanship that is one of the
most toxic elements of politics today
Donald Trump jr. is calling out the
Biden's for nepotism
it sounds like satire it sounds like an
onion article now I don't want to redo
this because I've already done it
I've not ignored the totally toxic
nature of the political status quo that
leads to someone like hunter Biden Joe
Biden's son to have a $50,000 a month
consulting contract with a Ukrainian gas
company I did an entire story about this
last week or the week before there is no
question that this is exactly the type
of thing that is endemic to our
political system
it's the revolving door of elected
officials and lawyers and lobbyists and
consultants including both themselves
and their family members and their
significant others we need to root it
out it's a problem there is no question
now that being said there was nothing
particularly egregious about the hunter
Biden consulting gig in the sense that
trumpets have been arguing the
conspiratorial way this is the system we
have it's a disgusting system it's a
corrupt system it has to be changed but
it's business as usual but then Donald
Trump jr. goes on Twitter and says
Biden's career hunter Biden's career is
based just on his dad's and that's bad
and that's corrupt his name is Donald
Trump jr. and he's saying that the name
Biden being a Biden has put hunter Biden
in a privileged position has irony died
take a look at this video clip from the
sean hannity program a very rehearsed
Donald Trump jr. trying to make this
case when you're the father and your
son's entire career is dependent on that
they own you Sean that's what it is
they've bought Biden Inc and they've
been doing it both domestically whether
it was MBNA bank whether it was Amtrak
whatever it was domestically when he was
a senator and had influence over
domestic policy and they started doing
it internationally the
second Joe Biden became vice president
and had authority abroad Donald Trump
jr. is criticizing someone else for
having a career built on their name and
their father's name so there are two
options here one is that Don jr. is
genuinely so dumb that he just doesn't
realize that his critique of Joe and
hunter Biden is relevant ten times over
about him and Eric Trump and Ivanka
Trump in relation to Donald Trump senior
the President of the United States
that's one possibility the other
possibility is he does get it but he
assumes Sean Hannity's audience and his
dad's followers are so dumb that they
won't notice the obvious hypocrisy of
him Donald Trump jr. criticizing Joe and
hunter Biden of nepotism the funny thing
is that this is actually something that
Don Jr is an authority on you know I
said last week we covered
lera Trump who's the wife of Eric Trump
being brought on to Fox News to comment
on Syria
what does Larry Trump know about Syria
and the Kurds absolutely nothing Don jr.
actually is an expert on nepotism and
how to use your father's name to get
money and speaking gigs and build a
career he's done it he is the right
person to be commenting about it the
problem is he's commenting about it as
if it's a problem he's observing rather
than something he's an example of and of
course that irony is not lost on many of
the leftists who have seen what has gone
on here hunter Biden was paid $50,000 a
month to consult for a Ukrainian gas
company is that a gig he would have had
if he wasn't Joe Biden's son of course
not of course not Donald Trump jr. is
making millions from the presidency of
his father is in a privileged and
powerful position where he more Ivanka
Trump their meeting with world leaders
they're sometimes sitting in for their
dad who is the President of the United
States would they have that if they
weren't Donald Trump's son obviously not
and this is a complete lack of
self-awareness made even more cartoonish
by the fact that his name is literally
the same name as two
right hunter Biden Joe Biden Donald
Trump Donald Trump jr. if having the
same last name as a former vice
president is lucrative what about having
just literally the same name as the
current president of the United States
my question to you is and I don't know
the answer to this is Don jr. dumb
enough that he doesn't realize the irony
of what he's saying or is he smart
enough to realize it but he just thinks
the people watching Sean Hannity are too
stupid to figure it out let me know by
either commenting on this video on
youtube or by sending me a tweet at D
Pakman we will take a quick break and be
back after this to talk about the best
thing that has ever happened to Tulsi
Gabbard okay if you've been paying
attention to the news over the last few
days maybe you know what it is it
relates to Hillary Clinton that's coming
up next today's program brought to you
in part by Blink accom slash Pakman
blinka s-- is a great service that I use
all the time what they do is they take
thousands of the most popular
non-fiction books including the newest
bestsellers they condense them into
15-minute audiobooks that you can listen
to and you still get the most crucial
information and insights from each book
and I've listened to a ton of books on
blink as' I recently checked out soccer
na mcc's by Simon Cooper we do have
after all the World Cup going on
recently we also have been talking about
BS jobs and there is a great new book of
BS jobs by David Graeber which I
listened to on bling cos they're
constantly adding new books to the
platform you will never run out of
fascinating and critically acclaimed
books to enjoy and our audience can get
a seven day free trial by going to blink
accom slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube I'm putting a link in the video
description and after the free trial if
you'd like it you can continue enjoying
thousands of condensed audiobooks for
about five bucks a month that's be li NK
is t.com /p
a que mas